you don't wanna talk about cuz we were
talking about tinder and how it's
affecting young men yeah and so we
actually have a couple different we have
a bunch of an articles about like men
working about emotional intelligence I
want to I want to talk about tinder
because I've been thinking about this
thing and I want to hear what your
thoughts I'm what I'm gonna tell you
okay there's a bunch of different things
like the first thing we're just talking
about is like there's that Gillette
commercial right where it's toxic
masculinity is bad and one of the scenes
was this guy is like standing up against
a building or something yeah and a woman
walks by and then he makes that face
like oh and then he walks towards her
and then the souther dude walks up and
puts his hand to stop him you know have
you seen it I don't remember the scene
so it's becoming like one it's become a
meme now where like they use this dude
who stops the man and like a variety of
difference are gonna go yeah don't do it
what what the reason that bothered me is
because like the dude didn't do anything
out of turn like he saw a pretty lady
and said oh and he went to go talk to
her is the implication he was going to
like harass her fine I get it but that's
not what we saw what we saw was a guy
saying don't interact with other human
beings if they're female I guess cuz
he's a male interacting with a male so
technically it was like this he's
interacting with someone but the crazy
thing about it is it's always so
pesimistic like true if dude the crazy
thing to me is man if you're a dude man
dude man bro dude man bro dude if you're
a guy and you see an attractive human
being and you're out outside no you go
up to him hey how's it going that's
literally how I met who I'm with now and
she's great and I regret nothing but
what if a dude came out of that cafe and
put his hand in front of her chest and
said oh don't do it bro I would have
walked around him excuse me yeah don't
touch me dude I'd be like Oh get your
hands off me don't touch me and it's
funny because my manager at the time was
like oh yeah you want to take this and
I'm like yes I do
excuse me I was working at a shop and
she walked in and I was just like wow I
need to talk to this girl so wait wait
wait you you were working at a business
I was yeah so that's that's sexual
harassment I know it's even worse right
dude you're fine you're fine you're out
right it's okay I quit
it's I quit the next day I'm like I
gotta follow this girl but so basically
like seeing that you know I'm thinking
of that video
don't Eve ever seen at 10 hours of
walking through New York as a woman I
saw that video yeah and it's like this
this this woman is walking through New
York but you've brought you guys have
all probably seen it and some of the
instances that they were complaining
about was a guy saying like how do you
do hello
yeah one of them was literally hello yep
like whoa oh how dare you say hello to
me heavens
I mean so but whatever worth some some
guys catcalling you know I gave borås of
course and like that's that's stupid but
some of them were like how's it going
have a nice day it's like the tinder
equivalent of super liking someone
though isn't it no I just what it what
is it guy supposed to do then if you
literally can't say hello to a woman
outside you can't even walk up to a
woman without a guy stopping and go whoa
bro toxic masculinity so now
everything's being relegated to the
Internet you know and now I want to get
into my hypothesis on tinder dating and
how it's affecting yeah withdrawing
everything I told me all the things that
I think I've told you this before but
let's let's let's talk about it so you
get women who do online dating right now
okay and you have these this culture
being bred by this mainstream you know
feminist narrative of men shouldn't talk
to women at all as my I know they'll
deny it if you say like you shouldn't
even talk no of course not just don't
harass but all the media they show us is
literally a guy just like talking right
not all of it but I definitely know
you're saying right no well they
exaggerated totally can't say hello well
what they're showing you is probably the
worst that can find you know and it's
not even that bad and not all of it some
of it so here's here's what happens I
was thinking about this because I was
talking to this young dude and he was
like 24 and he was a virgin mmm 24 in a
virgin oh yeah dude there's like some
ridiculous number in 2012 I think it was
something like 18 to 24-year old men
like 30% were virgins and that was years
ago
Wow yeah and now the number is people
under the age of twenty nine thirty
percent haven't had any relations
relations in the mess in the past year
30 percent of 29 year olds and under and
under no relation no no adult relations
in the past year okay but there's this
year so they're not necessarily virgins
but there is speculation they are based
on the previous data that you know you
know since since that last subscribe
came out we're seeing a massive spike in
a lack in a lack of adult adult activity
to say the least
okay here's our thing is happening okay
I was talking to this young guy and he
was complaining about how he couldn't
get dates and I'm like are you on tinder
and he's like of course he's on OkCupid
tinder he does all the online dating
stuff okay and so this actually plays
into one of the reasons I think men are
failing to launch and take on
responsibilities he's in college
mm-hmm all of the women around him the
same age before tinder before the
internet before social media yeah they
would only know him and his friends
right and so they were close lose them
right so if that woman was gonna be in a
relationship it was going to be with the
dude who was around the same age as her
right around the same status and as her
income and everything and that was it
yeah now everything's changed now if you
look at okay cupid's data you have most
guys one a message 22 year-olds no
matter how old they get no matter what
no matter what it's like it barely
fluctuates like 60-year old guy 20 to 50
year old guy 20 to 70 22 Wow women go
for the men around their own age for the
most part okay
we check us out so even the 22 year old
yeah yeah yeah presumably based on okay
get get scales up okay okay but here's
what's happening it's not about age at
all in my opinion this is my hypothesis
I could be wrong
I'm just looking at the data so you get
these 22 year old women who go on tinder
and they're swiping you know they can
basically swipe on whoever they want
like that's how the game works with with
online dating women have all the men
line up and they just like the guys they
like and they get to message them that's
just how it is okay women are the ones
who get messaged men are the one who
message so men go on on tinder and they
swipe everybody mm-hm and then hope some
woman swipes them back so that they're
actually interested in right well the
women get to be like I like this guy
swipe and then they message women yeah
guys are just like fingers crossed hope
she messaged me I don't know
yeah or hope she likes me mm-hmm so that
dude I was talking to I'm like I think I
know why he's a virgin and can't get a
date he's broke in college in debt
they're both on tinder right she looks
at his profile young broke in college
he's kind of attractive maybe she'll
swipe on him yeah then all of a sudden
comes tall dark
handsome 33 year old with a brand new
car it's a Honda Civic 2012 and he lives
in a crappy two but two bedroom
apartment and got his own place he's got
his own bird he's got a job he's got
Michael in the bank and so these older
guys will swipe on this young attractive
woman because they don't care she's hot
oh yes wipe and then she sees him and
she's like oh yeah cool he's got his own
car he's got his own apartment swipe and
they message and he goes and out let's
just assume it was based on appearance
only okay she knows nothing about age
nothing about income she swipes in the
24 year old dude in college and she
swipes on this dude okay and they both
message okay dude says want to come over
to my mom's basement and hang out while
I play xbox and she's like no I think
it's while I'm broke and she's like
maybe then also the other message pops
up you want to come to my apartment in
the hipster neighborhood in New York and
watch movies on widescreen TV what watch
movies on my 42 inch TV because it was
on sale at Walmart what you gonna pick
mom's house college dorm I was convicted
so that was dude right exactly so even
if it was the dudes in college ins got
his own dorm it's like my dorm mates
will be gone by 9:00 and you can come
over and she might say sure right yeah
but women have all the men lining up and
they can choose whoever they want for
the most part not all women right all
right you know obviously but then you
end up with in the way I see a
disproportionate amount of college men
competing now with a wider radius of
successful established men what tinder
an OkCupid has done is made it so that
the dating pool for men becomes infinite
basically yeah they can pick any city
they want and then what happens when you
get a dude who's 35 he makes 50k a year
not a big salary guy maybe he works for
BuzzFeed yeah but he does have a little
bit of savings and he says we can take a
trip or we can take a helicopter tour
it's not that expensive it's a couple
under bucks and then she gets the broke
dorm guy who's like me and my dorm mates
are gonna hang out smoke pot or I've
saved up a couple weeks of my paycheck
from the ice cream shop I work at not
even he's in college he's broke debt
oh yeah so yeah maid got nothing I know
I know a lake we can walk around so this
I think contributes to men's failures
failures to launch because now I'm
talking to this dude and I'm like are
you 24 and you've never
like what happened and even that even
that you asking him that's like a like
people get defensive that that feels
almost like an attack another dude he
was interested I know I know but just it
feels like as an average if you were to
ask somebody who was in that situation
and you go what happened why why are you
like what's wrong with you that's what
it sounds like even that's what it
sounds like over here anyway like what
is that but he brought it up to me right
right now and we're these guys this guy
wants to figure it out yeah he wants to
improve himself and figure out why he's
failing to date mm-hm and I think you
know the first simple mathematical
reason is just that it's that before
mobile phones and apps and social media
yeah a woman would look at the immediate
man in her in her social circle you know
in high school or college right but now
it's it's anywhere you know you've
expanded your range from like the few
blocks around your high school to
literally I mean when I was in high
school I was on well I would I didn't go
to high school but when I was high
school age we had MySpace I hope MySpace
dude I I was I was all of a sudden like
the girls in my neighborhood didn't
matter anymore right because I could go
on MySpace and see literally every
single girl in the Chicagoland area yeah
and be like hey how's it going hey Wow
and then you do a message back hey how's
it going and I would drive you know 20
miles and I'm the suburb mouths do you
got a car you can drive it yeah right
yeah so those rounds I had a car I was
like 18 but even before that when I was
like 16 17 I'd like you come pick me up
but I was like this arrogant
skateboarder who was like all tractive
and all the girls were like oh they
wanted to come pick me up not but I will
say in all actuality was probably just
attrition yeah like I'll message 50
girls and one of them will give me a
ride and they would write so so it
worked out but that's always been the
game since since social media it's like
message as many women as possible cross
your fingers okay but so that I think
really started to change things now
you've got guys who haven't had to be
responsible and interact with women and
try to compete to be something of value
in society okay I think a big factor and
whether or not men become you know like
strong and charismatic has to do with
well I shouldn't say a big part of it
has to do with them trying to impress
someone else typically a woman you know
that's how many who that's interesting
you say that how many guys have thrown
them off a building on a skateboard when
like the hot chick walks by how many
guys you know are like yo look at me and
they try and do something like amazing
feat I mean it doesn't even have to be
for a girl I mean it's it's something to
be said about being admired or being you
know looked at like wow that person did
something awesome like I admire them and
that that feeling is awesome like we
talked about it the other day you know
when was that first time that you
remember being like like a strong
confident man you know yeah and I said
it was like when I went on stage for the
first time and played music live you
know it was like how old are you I think
I was 21
wow that's a year older I was older yeah
I was in high school I was short and
small I you know and I didn't really
have a lot of friends I played D&D and
magic so that was it you were done in
the corner yeah of school and like you
know yeah I didn't do anything and I
didn't think about girls I was not that
was not on my agenda and then you know I
I didn't go to college either I went
straight to New York and started working
but it was that that feeling that I got
I was like suddenly and it's being
admired people want to be admired they
want to be wanted and that's what
socially acceptable also yeah they want
to be accepted in the group so like if
you're a skateboarding group you know
and you have like that one kid that just
sucks you know and it's like when he
lands that first kickflip everybody in
the park is gonna be like yeah yeah like
you got your kickflip and it's like
that's the best feeling in the world and
that kid will forever be changed from
that one moment you know you make it
that's a really good point too because I
think it's not just the dating apps it's
the digital world in general yeah cuz
people are isolating themselves into
smaller and smaller tribes yep and
you're less likely to interact with
people so when I would go to the skate
park it was a park in general it was
surrounded by tennis courts so right we
would go skate at the local park and all
of the other kids from the area would be
hanging out there too for whatever
reason playing basketball like you know
tennis or whatever I feel few of them do
play tennis I don't know don't ask me it
was kind of yeah I played tennis pretty
soon but then most of the people who are
hanging out at the park box I grew up
there's a part called vidum Park over by
Midway and
Southwest at Chicago people would be
hanging out and it would really really
funny to unlike some some chick would
come in like chillin tennis court and
like getting away and it's like they're
just there because that's where everyone
hangs out you know but now if you're
hanging out online with like video games
with your buddies
it's very insular it's very isolated
it's polarizing people into like little
tiny groups of different like pods of
ideas and you get stuck there
now take that that factor that these
subcultures are very much like you can
be in your house and not go out into the
world especially concerned the fact a
lot of video games and online platforms
like very few women play and then you
have women on tinder and all of a sudden
it's the older guys the next generation
the older Millennials you know who are
easily just you know they've got cash
they got a car and they're like hey lady
and it's like they're done playing video
games so so what do you thinks gonna
happen in in 10 years when like it's
it's like the the scale of men who are
not in relationships not having families
is going up and up and up if you were
concerned about the birthrate now being
bad because we're not at replacement
levels we thing can happen in 20 years
well it's just like he was saying the
other day on the podcast you know it's
just like you know guys are you know
they're I forget I forget what he said
I'm trying to I'm trying to think of
Jack Murphy yeah I know Jack Murphy but
I'm trying to think of what he said
exactly in what was a topic just about
men being men you know being allowed to
be men basically and well let's let's do
this let's start a new segment let's
grab some super chair true and then
we'll jump into the next story about how
it's actually this modern feminism so I
thought it would be you know we didn't
actually plan that one out it was just
kind of like talking about Bosman yeah
right as we were getting in so we got a
bunch of these stories about like how
it's not just about men it's about how
schools don't teach you to be in control
or aware of your emotions and there's
nothing to do with dudes it has to do
with women too and so you end up with
extremists in politics who are not
self-aware don't care about you are not
empathetic and they go around screeching
because they have no idea what they're
feeling or why and me me me me me right
totally and so this is a contributing
factor to this so thanks for checking
out this segment from the Tim cast IRL
podcast we do the show every Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. sometimes an
hour or two
and we do have a full live recorded
version of the show that includes a lot
of comments and smaller segments you
probably don't see if you want to check
that out you can watch live at 8:00 p.m.
Monday through Friday or become a member
of this channel and for five bucks a
month you get full access to all of the
recorded podcasts every day after the
show we make them available in the
community section of this YouTube
channel so don't forget to subscribe and
stick around for more segments and more
shows Monday through Friday at 8 p.m.
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all in the next show
you